je vais mettre dans le contexte
peut-être une certaine tension voilà qui
n'excuse pas tout mais principalement
informations révélation de cette
audition Mohamed Tifaoui a bénéficié
d'un contrat de consultant auprès du
cipdr alors que et on le rappelle il
était salarié de l'association qui
bénéficiait de subventions de ce pdf
c'est une révélation vous nous dites
surpris c'est une révélation
on a du mal à voir des
personnes à voir plusieurs emplois à
temps plein
c'est une information nouvelle qui nous
a interpellé évidemment même si
comment Monsieur Sifaoui avait nous a
expliqué avoir des capacités de travail
hors norme il dit aussi que ils se sont
trahis par les mensonges les
approximations et la politique d'amnésie
qui a mené sur ce dossier il pointe vers
Marlène Schiappa non c'est ça il a été
abandonné en race campagne hier par
Marine je sais pas et aujourd'hui il
avait des mots très durs envers la
ministre oui tout en l'exonérant de
malversation de voir de responsabilité
puis à la fin il a eu
plusieurs incises quand même très durs
voilà où on voyait en tous les cas
largement me semble-t-il l'ombre de la
ministre non seulement plané mais être
attaqué avec beaucoup de vivacités pour
qu'il n'y a même peut-être pas je dirais
la le suivi
administratif au travers des assemblées
générales éventuelles sur l'évolution
les administrateurs enregistrés en
préfecture et ce sur les documents qui
sont qui sont fournis sont pas les mêmes
qu'est-ce qui se jouent autour de cette
US PPPM je pense qui se joue me
semblait-il cette association
certainement la volonté d'un travail
commun sous l'autorité du pouvoir
politique et de son administration dans
ce domaine là et ayant identifié un
acteur une personnalité certains disent
un expert enfin voilà quelqu'un qui
manifestement
avait trouvé avec des clés de passage et
bien la moitié de lui de lui donner une
place à défaut que ce soit intuitus
personnel en tous les cas avec un outil
support et le fond Marianne
permettez pour des associations donc
peut-être raccroché à une association il
y a eu beaucoup d'impressions lorsque
j'ai tenté d'obtenir des dates et puis
des adhésion voilà donc c'est pour ça
que Daniel Breuillet a ce micro à votre
place il y a quelques semaines parler de
Républic des copains ou en tout cas de
soupçons autour de cette réplique des
copains alors ce terme a vraiment été
voilà dénoncé en audition ce matin par
Mohamed Tifaoui et vous comprenez que
des observateurs puissent se dire cela
je vais pas me placer sur
les termes employés par les uns par les
autres mais on voit bien qu'il y a
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'incohérences un
manque évident de rigueur enfin on est
sur je rappelle une ambition forte un
combat quasiment de très haut rangs du
gouvernement de la République à travers
une ministre mais quand même du
gouvernement République à l'issue de
l'attentat de Samuel Paty sa mémoire à
Samuel Paty ne mérite pas d'être sal je
pense qu'on a une exigence et un devoir
d'éthique au regard de ces événements et
de ses valeurs à laquelle on dit être
attaché évidemment
liberté a été fraternité mais aussi
effectivement laïcité et le combat
contre le séparatisme il ne faut pas
transiger avec cette exigence et je
crois malheureusement les dernières
auditions nous ont montré qu'il y avait
finalement ce lien cette exigence on en
est me semble-t-il très éloigné les
résultats sont assez navrant c'est ça
monsieur Husson c'est ma dernière
question mais quand on se dit que notre
politique publique en matière de lutte
contre la radicalisation elle est voilà
avec de tels dysfonctionnements quand on
regarde à l'intérieur et qu'on creuse un
peu le fonctionnement du cepda est-ce
qu'on se dit pas que il y a de grave
manquements dans la façon dont la petite
publique de lutte contre la
radiocalisation et menée en France
au-delà du fond Marianne alors au-delà
du fond Marianne je pense que on a un
devoir de changer de braquet
certainement en utilisant plusieurs
outils pour s'attaquer à ces discours
séparatisme à tout ce qui viendrait
ébranler notre République sur ses
fondamentaux il ne faut rien lâcher il
faut y aller au corps à corps mettre à
mettre parce que je pense que ce combat
le mérite c'est un combat qui est un
combat évidemment national mais
universel on le sent aujourd'hui est
manifestement nous n'avons pas les bons
outils le fond morian aurait pu être
l'occasion d'expérimenter des procédés
notamment pour aller au combat sur les
réseaux sociaux manifestement on n'est
pas du tout à la hauteur du rendez-vous
premier initialement et bien merci merci
Monsieur Husson juste un dernier mot il
nous reste quelques secondes mais est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment d'avoir mis
au jour quelque chose vous y attendiez
un tel niveau de dysfonctionnement en
lançant non mais vous connaissez ces
scandale cette commission enquête je le
dis aujourd'hui à chaque audition il
s'est passé quelque chose et toujours
quelque chose d'inattendu donc il faut
regarder maintenant sereinement
froidement et objectivement nous avons
un devoir de vérité de la part de notre
assemblée du Sénat sur le contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et la dépense
publique sans oublier quand même
au-dessus de tout ne pas salir la
mémoire de Samuel Paty et les valeurs
que devait porter le fond Marianne ou
manifestement je l'ai dit la maille a
été très lâche
[Musique]